When you're a cinephile, you get used to disappointment.
After all, Hollywood can't deliver the goods
all the time.
Sure, Infinity War was pretty great, but we've
still got Justice League to deal with.
Hunger Games might've torn it up at the box
office, but Divergent couldn't quite make
it to the finish line.
Jurassic Park defined blockbuster cinema for
a generation.
Its sequel, The Lost World: Jurassic Park?
Eh, not so much.
That's how it's been forever, and yet it still
stings when a film fails to meet our expectations,
especially when that means bungling a scene
that we've waited years, sometimes decades,
to see unfold on the big screen.
Here's a not-so-fond look back at movie moments
that Hollywood failed to deliver.
The Phoenix rises (and falls)
When Jean Grey gave her life at the end of
X2: X-Men United, sacrificing herself to save
her teammates, X-Men fans knew what was coming,
and they couldn't wait.
After all, "The Dark Phoenix Saga" is considered
one of the best X-Men storylines of all time.
Well, Fox and Brett Ratner didn't get the
memo.
In the comics, Jean Grey realizes that the
only way to keep the universe safe from the
Dark Phoenix's power is by ending her own
life.
And, yes, it's just as heartbreaking as it
sounds.
In X-Men: The Last Stand, that's not how things
go.
At all.
Instead of using Cyclops as an emotional anchor,
Jean ends his life offscreen, early in the
film.
In the comics, the Dark Phoenix wreaks havoc
across space.
In The Last Stand, she kinda just, well, stands
around looking moody.
When she kicks the bucket, it's Wolverine
who does the deed, not Jean herself, robbing
the former Marvel Girl of both her agency
and her most heroic moment.
It's not a tragically inevitable ending.
It's a huge waste of audiences' time and money.
A Stark reality
Iron Man, A.K.A.
Tony Stark, makes up for a lack of memorable
minor baddies by butting heads with one utterly
evil arch-nemesis.
His name is the Mandarin, and he's bad news.
With a bunch of magic rings that grant him
special abilities, he's a real thorn in Stark's
side, in the comics, at least.
While the Mandarin was originally slated to
appear in Iron Man numero uno, he was written
out of the movie shortly before filming in
order to streamline the plot.
That's why ol' Shellhead's biggest fans were
excited when Iron Man 3 rolled around and
it looked like Tony Stark's number one bad
guy was going to make his long-awaited debut.
Surprise!
That's not what happened at all.
Instead, Stark learns that Ben Kingsley's
Mandarin is just an actor playing a part.
"Don't hurt the face!
I'm an actor!"
Fans weren't pleased.
In fact, the backlash was so intense that
Marvel "apologized" by releasing a short film
that reveals the "real" Mandarin is still
out there.
That guy, though?
He still hasn't showed up on-screen.
A Shire left unscoured
Here's a fun bit of literary trivia: The Lord
of the Rings saga doesn't end with Sauron's
defeat.
In The Return of the King's penultimate chapter,
"The Scouring of the Shire," Frodo, Sam, Merry,
and Pippin return home to bands of ne'er-do-wells
roaming the streets and machines belching
black smoke into the sky.
After realizing this was the handiwork of
disgraced wizard Saruman, Frodo and his friends
have no choice but to fight back, and it is
badass.
Unfortunately, Peter Jackson's big-screen
adaptation ignores "The Scouring of the Shire's"
action-packed ending.
Instead, it relegates the whole event to a
brief vision that Frodo sees when he looks
into the mirror of Galadriel.
OK, let's be real: "The Scouring of the Shire"
isn't exactly a crowd-pleaser, but it's an
important part of the story.
Without it, The Return of the King ends on
a tiresome string of happy endings.
Oh well.
At least Saruman got his just desserts in
the deleted scenes.
Cursed cameos
It's easy to forget these days, with the Pirates
of the Caribbean franchise focusing heavily
on Johnny Depp's wacky Jack Sparrow, but Orlando
Bloom's Will Turner was once the lead character
of the flicks.
As time went on, however, his character became
less and less important to the Pirates franchise.
In fact, he didn't appear in On Stranger Tides,
the fourth entry in the series, at all.
So, as you can imagine, Pirates fans were
rightfully excited to see Bloom's big return
in the franchise's fifth installment, Dead
Men Tell No Tales.
Then they saw the movie.
As it turns out, Bloom's role is little more
than a glorified cameo.
He appears at the beginning to introduce the
McGuffin, and then returns at the end for
a brief conclusion.
The real heavy lifting is done by Brenton
Thwaites, who plays Turner's son, and Depp,
who'll keep making these things as long as
Disney keeps paying him.
It was a major disappointment.
Still, Bloom fared better than Knightley:
while she's got a cameo in the film as well,
she doesn't get a single line of dialogue.
Buzzkill
Taken together, the two Kill Bill movies run
for 247 minutes.
You know how long it takes the Bride to actually
end Bill's life?
24 seconds.
That's it.
It takes more than 11 times that for the Bride
to whack Vernita Green, the first victim on
her revenge tour.
Daryl Hannah's Elle lasts for over five minutes
before the Bride plucks her other eye out.
The fight against O-Ren Ishii's yakuza enforcers
at the House of Blue Leaves goes on for nearly
seven minutes, and it takes just under five
to put O-Ren herself down for good.
Basically, Kill Bill's entire hook is its
kinetic, hyper-stylized, and lengthy action
scenes, and yet when it comes to the most
important one-on-one battle in the story,
the one that both films are named after — it's
over in the blink of an eye.
As far as the flick's characters and themes
go, it's a fine ending that demonstrates the
Bride's conflicted relationship with Bill.
Viewers who wanted the movie to end with a
fight worthy of the series, however, couldn't
help but want a little more.
Later, Vader
Ask any Star Wars fanatic, and they'll set
the scene for you: Anakin, burned alive, lies
on the operating table.
He's betrayed the Jedi Order, and driven away
both his lover and his closest friend.
He has nothing left.
Slowly, the operation proceeds, and young
Skywalker is transformed into the devious
Darth Vader.
Broken, both physically and mentally, Vader
asks about Padmé's fate.
The Emperor tells Vader that she has passed
on.
And, worse, that Vader himself was responsible.
Furious, the newly crowned Sith Lord breaks
free from his restraints, stumbles forward
like a drunk bantha, raises his arms to the
sky, and screams, "Noooooo!"
And just like that, all the tension leaks
out.
This is arguably the most important moment
in the prequel trilogy — if not the entire
franchise — and for some reason, George
Lucas decided to make his tragic villain react
like a spoiled child.
"NOT COOL.
TOTALLY LAAAME."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!